it's all over hello everybody my name is
Kamal Drummond and today you were
talking about painting a picture of
mural data and no it's not an image
clash of image classification dataset
where we can look at previous artwork
and identify other artists my hey that
mural which although it might be cool
but we're gonna actually talk about how
we can leverage storytelling and empathy
within day science process and
understand how that can help us as data
scientists and communicating key
stakeholders and ultimately how that
helps us with in the decision making
process so before I begin actually a
little bit introduction about myself so
currently I'm a senior at Brooklyn
College and I major in psychology and
throughout my undergrad most of my
education has been around understanding
people and the way they interact with
the world and how that world affects
them and throughout my time it's I took
a statistics class I found that like
just like psychology data was a way to
learn more about people the way we are
behaviors and how we study them and
throughout college I've had the
privilege of working in really great
places I started as an artist painting
murals here in New York City and then I
started interning at public agencies
tech startups and entertainment and what
I found throughout that process was that
data was really a hallmark in how people
made decisions we maybe have a dataset
on how crime rates in New York City
maybe we try and analyze ways to prevent
clients from turning and so that way we
can understand how stakeholders can
learn more about their company their
organization or even agency and how we
can better leverage that within day
science process so what are we gonna
learn today so we're gonna cover three
topics
the first one is introducing the concept
of mural data the second one is
understanding what is data storytelling
and the third one is discussing the role
of empathy in data science and so how
these all come into play is
understanding how does the value of
context how does the value of
understanding the underlying aspects of
the data help us communicate with
stakeholders and learning more about our
companies and organizations so what is
neural data so like I said I used to be
an artist I done projects on criminal
justice immigration and mental health
and the way would work is that the my
team and I we will go out into
communities we painted in and we talk to
people we learn more about their lives
in their stories and we learn about you
know sort of we gain more information of
learning about how they interact with
the world and we use that information to
help us come up with our designs as you
see here in this first mural we we
tackle the prison industrial complex so
we want to learn how you know privatize
prisons how the negative effects have
been having on underserved communities
and so as you can see here my second
girl our American narrative continues
here we can see the same similar aspect
of information about people's lives and
house hi it's immigration we're the Arab
parents who might immigrated to the
United States go through the same
struggles as their ancestors who deal
with the same matter and even with
mental health how in communities we
create a caring environment for young
children to develop and to you know
growing adults that can ultimately
contribute to the betterment of society
and it's really about laying that
foundation as communities families and
ultimately allowing people to grow into
these positive contributors to society
so of course with all this information
that we get from people whether it's
about you know
personal attachment of when their
parents first came to America or you
know you know their their desire to be
positive contributors of where they want
to be in the world
it comes with information and when we
look back at the president duster
complex girl here here is one example
where we can look at the march on
Memphis Tennessee when dr. Martin Luther
King jr. he was marching with sanitation
workers who are on strike for for a
better treatment in their lives in their
workplace and so we use that as a way to
talk about the I am and man mantra and
discussing the aspects of like one be
treated as equal equal people and so
that's how we understand the aspect of
taking information and ultimately
boiling down into visual representations
of a above neural and so ultimately what
you have is that neural data is a way of
thinking through data to communicate a
message and your dataset essentially is
the canvas so you're piling through
numbers possibly and you're trying to
find patterns through all this
information and you'll compile that
together to maybe create visual
representations to key stakeholders and
identify key aspects in which they can
improve their organizations and
regardless of the type of art artists
always conveyed messages so maybe we did
graffiti maybe didn't URLs maybe
canvases were a thing or drawing this
the same aspect between all that was we
communicate messages we took information
you compile it together and we told
stories of underserved communities that
were no voice in the world it's the same
thing with day scientists where we start
to see that you regardless if you are in
the healthcare field in marketing
finance
or even public service it all boils down
to how you can think like artists and
convey messages to key stakeholders and
in that sense they themselves are able
to understand how can we improve
you know organizations that respect and
ultimately the way we can understand
people is the same way that we can
understand data you know as a
psychologist you have a client who comes
into a meeting you sit down with them
and you get to know them like what is
how how did you like going where are
some issues that you're dealing with and
ultimately you use that information to
help develop recommendations to better
their lives it's the same thing with
data you have a client maybe it's your
stakeholder and maybe it's someone
you're doing consulting for and you're
doing a analysis for them that analysis
how is how you get to know them and you
do conversations about what they want to
better themselves through the day
analytics and ultimately the analysis
you come up with is something that could
boil down to recommendations for them it
all starts with how storytelling infuses
life into numbers there's a famous
psychologist his name is Daniel Kahneman
he goes no one ever made a decision
because of a number they need a story so
you need stories you need context that
helps give meaning to the data you did
analysis you're providing for people and
a garner reported that actually actually
50% of data science projects fail due to
bad storytelling and that ultimately
leads to a data consumption problem so
not only are you not telling the story
properly but you're also preventing your
stake holder from being able to
understand what is the issue that
they're dealing with and
how can they better improve their
companies if they all know what's going
on however become mistakes and data
visualization affects our ability to
appeal to our visual perception of
messages you know it's a natural human
beings that the way we it's better that
we process information visually because
we were able to see how you know see how
changes might occur or a given time
however from a data visualization
perspective you know when you're
understand like how values aren't
properly represented in the first chart
right over there
61% doesn't look as much as it shouldn't
really look very similar to seventy
percent or maybe forty two percent
shouldn't really look a bit like twenty
two percent and even with a second one
like we start to see like there are too
many factors into play that you're just
really hard to distinguish like one bar
from another and from the third one not
everything I'm necessarily must be
represented in this data visualization
because as we see here like they're the
hundred most active tweeters but it's
really hard to discern between one
tweeter or the other so maybe if I'm a
from a marketing agency and I don't look
for social media influencers I probably
be hard it'd be hard for me to know from
which of these um tweeters that are
probably most active they're reaching
out to people more that could actually
target and help improve my business and
often this leads to a disconnect between
the data and key stakeholders and this
connection is really important because
as I mentioned for like stakeholders
they want to learn more how can a better
their companies how can they better the
agencies and the data scientist is the
person who helps bridge that together
you are the person who is analyzing data
who's communicating and presenting it to
people who sometimes don't usually have
a background analytics so if you have
the information and you have the
information seeker then the person who's
presenting the information sort of
struggles to correctly understand what's
going on in the company and thus the
stakeholder isn't able to make these
Corrections with an organisation and
again what happens when there is a
disconnect information struggles to get
to the key stakeholder and most
importantly the progress of change
stagnates when again we don't know
what's going on you really you really
aren't sure what areas to prove upon and
that's sort of gets away scary because
maybe you want you know you have
competition that's always improving
every day and if you're like a CEO for
like a product manager how do you
improve your company and keep up with
everyone else when you don't even know
what's going on in your own organization
so we came up with the five steps of
storytelling we have the first step
which is to introduce the data is
overall topic here is where you start to
learn more about the data's background
its history
how has the topic been an issue over a
given period of time
has there been any change is there
anything notable that we should keep in
mind when we're going into the analysis
itself here on the second step is where
we introduce the data here is where we
want to start to understand the
limitations of the data in regards to
what problem it can actually solve so
you this little can touch on this a
little bit but each data set you know
under any given category where the
healthcare for example healthcare itself
has many different categories like
marketing
and so yes thing to yourself what's the
specific part of health care would be
would we be able to address getting the
data set that we have and ultimately
this would come down to the possible
conclusions we can make with it and the
third step is how do we identify
significant or insignificant
relationships here is where we start to
understand if something you know is
anything notable that pops out and data
maybe you find statistical significance
maybe you start to find the you specify
analysis that supports what's been going
on within the historical context of the
topic or maybe you find a date we find
analysis that goes against the current
trends of a problem and start to think
like are we debunk a myth or are we sort
of like agreeing upon this is what's
actually go this is what's actually
going on and for the fourth step is
where we connect key points to the topic
so by this point you have your analysis
and you have your key points and now we
have to think critically how it relates
to the problem so if you have us if you
have a significant value what does that
mean if you know against a problem is it
something that could help us solve the
issue who can benefit from understanding
the significance and what what what sort
of projects can we build to implement
instrumental results that will help
improve your organization and fifth is
where we empathize here is where we
start to realize how that the data
itself we start to think about different
ways that we can solve problems and we
can take the analysis and you know start
putting together projects and
understanding key points within not only
the dataset itself but with an
organization that may be the project
manager needs to hire new people maybe
we need to
build a device that can help us solve
this problem or maybe we just need just
change up the culture you know so we're
gonna go through each step one by one
with a actual data set itself we have
the average wait times in the US
emergency departments so as I'm sure
anybody who can tell you this emoji is
not it can't do the justice enough and
how exhausted it exhausted it is to wait
an emergency room imagine you come in
and you're waiting to see a doctor and
you're in pain but your wings extends in
that time and we can see that the
average wait times in United States has
been increasing in 2003 it was actually
at forty six point five minutes and then
and it increased by by twenty five
percent to fifty eight point one minutes
and so given this understanding of
increased wait time we start to see how
there is a ongoing issue without the
data is trending towards a bigger
problem over a given time now we're
going to introduce the data itself here
is where we start to talk about the the
type of problem within the healthcare
field that the data Gasol so as I
mentioned for healthcare has its own
different subcategories right there's
patient survival rates there's drug
development and then there's emergency
department wait times and given our data
set it does not mention anything in
regards to patient survival rates so it
doesn't also mention anything in regards
to drug development so essentially any
conclusions we draw from this data set
cannot relate to those two subcategories
what it does talk about is emergency
department wait times
so any conclusions we draw would be in
relation to that specific subcategory
and this is common amongst any fields
for example public service there is
public service for criminal justice
whether you want to talk about mental
health within um within prisons
recidivism amongst others so now we're
going to identify significant or
insignificant relationships so here is
where we highlight key points in the
data and helps it helps identify
patterns and helps patterns stick out
here we can see that in the north north
eastern part of the United States that
they are their top five longest areas
within the country but within the north
mid United States they're the bottom
five longest so we started to see like
there is some geographical difference
between areas so that's what made keys
to think about what's what's so
important what's so different in Montana
as opposed to New York State that
they're doing something different that
me might have to look into of course
this is only a highlighted point within
the data and so would have to do is that
this opens up more doors to think about
what specific parts of the state of
Montana makes it so good that they're
one of the top five lowest wait times
than the emergency department before
you're admitted
and so here is where we get to connect
key points to the topic so as a metaphor
we have the state of Montana is
considered to be rural area in
comparison to states like New York which
are considered urban and this is
actually key because studies have shown
that longer wait times
we're associated with the type of area
you live in so if you live in an urban
area you'll be waiting accurate average
around sixty two point four minutes but
if you're living in a rural non urban
area you're living like you're waiting
of around forty minutes to be seen and
urban areas are one of the studies
consider that urban areas are considered
to be more populous so in a sense you're
jamming up the ER room with more people
within a given area you have more people
who are likely to visit room and of
course there are only so many doctors
within the hospital and in this sort
becomes an issue because with more
people entering an area there's less
attention that could be given to anyone
else so that's what that's been seen as
a main contributor to wait times
here is where ever began is where we
begin sympathize
so the impact extends beyond the scope
of the data so we came up with three
different recommendations based on
analysis that we had say for example
Brenda was an engineer she saw this
analysis and she thought to herself what
can I do for the patients while they're
at least waiting to be seen
well apparent she came up with an idea
where she wants to develop a device that
takes a patient's information such as
their blood type and it's transmitted to
the hospital's database so until again
mid to the bed at least that sort of
information is ready to go when they
eventually get seen by the doctor
there's also Joe
Joe is a hospital manager he now decided
give him the information he's seen he
wants to know he wants to speak to
doctors and he wants to know what's
going on floor every day he wants to get
their perspective of the issues that
they're dealing with and understand what
comes go comes about we're trying to
treat patients we're gonna try and get
one person out of bed and another person
into it all but it's the same time
maintaining a quality service of
healthcare for each of those patients
and finally we have Rebecca she's a top
physician assistant at one of Montana's
hospitals and so she's been sent to New
York to train staff at their second
Hospital about ways to manage patients
in timely effective way so what we see
here is that we had we had a data set we
had an analysis and we found key points
within that data and so what we have
here is that we've had people from
different hierarchies within the
organization itself we've had some one
more which has a more administrative
position someone who
an actual on the floor with doctors and
also we have you know technology comes
into play with this you know as
technology we can start to understand
what sort of devices or maybe an app you
can build that sort of helps us you know
improve the process and so ultimately
data is more than just black and white
as data scientists we need to start
thinking more not just data in a way of
here is a here is it here is a numerical
output here is said numbers and let's
come up with an analysis what it
actually is is more than its IQ putting
meets EQ it's our intelligence and being
able to analyze the data as well as our
intelligence to be able to put that data
into context and understand what goes on
under the hood and one one one
perspective and again with context we
get to see below the surface level of
our insights one way think of it is like
the iceberg effect like if anyone has
ever been seeing an iceberg result if we
know that on the surface it looks might
not look so big but I'm sure if we
looked on the water those things are
huge and this very similar thing how we
think of data science like yeah you
might have machine learning you might
have statistical analysis and you might
have data visualization and you can flip
through the data and find key insight
but it goes beyond that there's idea of
content masters people who are very
familiar with the fuel so when we were
talking about Joe a hospital manager
wanting to meet with doctors so Joe is
gaining more information and those
conversations with those doctors who
have a very significant background
treating patients understanding what
goes on on day to day basis and of
course you have patterns when we start
talking about how we take information
loads information actually and we
compile that into concise yet effective
understandings of the data set and the
world within it
so we're takeaways right storytelling
with data is an art as much of a data
science we need to think you need to
think like artists where we take
information convey them like can be them
individual messages here is where we
start to think more about how this the
fact that there's so much information in
the world and when you have such a
rather very large data set you really
just want to touch on the key points
because as a stakeholder you start to
think okay I have this much information
XYZ yet happen given Y given Y I found
out but X Y Z I can now go do this to
actually help implement instrumental
plans within my organization or company
for the second part we have insights you
derive from data come from more than
just a numerical outputs when context
concept helps us understand the reason
particular outcome may may have arisen
when we were thinking back to the the
highlighted values on a map when areas
in Northeast were very high in wait
times as opposed to the north of Mid
America it just all I did was point out
a point that point out a difference in
the data it still didn't tell us why
something is happening that sort of
voice dress that
anyway and what happens it opens up
other avenues to explore within a data
center probably future projects if
anyone's you ever read an academic
article where there's they're like
always a key part goes towards the end
which which introduces future
implications where we start to
understand that data is a content the
way we analyze data is always continuous
process where where we have one analysis
it might help us think about other ways
and other type today we might want to
look into to help drive up and change
and ultimately its understanding the
importance of so what so data scientists
can be thought of as advisors throughout
the decision-making process when you're
a person who has a large amount of
information you almost in a sense are
able to take their information analyze
it and come up with recommendations to
help your company organization and that
sort of thing becomes holds a great deal
of responsibility because now you're
thinking about how it may be influencing
the key stakeholder who's signing off on
particular project and that's where your
responsibility that's sort of
responsible at the data scientist comes
into play I think there's really one
last thing to finish off with so as an
artist one of the thing that always
sticks with me is that at a conversation
one time my the one that had artist I
worked with she goes to me I'm your old
self we're not solve world hunger but if
it inspired people to want to solve that
world hunger then it's not a shop which
means that at the end of the day a mural
is really aesthetically beautiful
but the true value is in this meeting
and how inspires people that's what I'm
a change so if you're a person that goes
wow like this is what's going on in our
world this is what's going on in our
communities I need to do something then
it's not shut it's same thing with data
a dataset itself analysis itself will
not solve the problem but if we can you
can tell stories with the data and
create very insightful information from
it then itself helps people understand
more about the world we live in in a way
we become psychologists that give people
recommendations about how can we improve
people's lives and as artists we start
to think about how how can we paint that
picture per say the mural Tito and
ultimately improve the quality of life
the world thank you any questions or
Oh
that was the project itself so the data
came from the National Institute of
national institutes at Six's the Miami
center they were the treatment
ProPublica there's there's very
different analysis that's done the day
like that and so of course that of
course it that could and really to other
researchers in healthcare maybe start
thinking about do people have health
insurance has effect whether they get
admitted for others and both from why
I've seen in the data No
so in the dataset itself there was
information regarding the medical
condition that someone had for it for
the sake of this talk we just focused on
just way times itself but then again
like even when you bring up that point
it just goes to show like other avenues
we can take an analysis maybe if we
looked at state and medical condition is
see to how that varies across say New
York and DC and Montana but but
definitely
from my from where I remember there was
an address
it wasn't address of each hospital so
over there we would be able to parse
that address to get the city but the way
the data was set up in this data set was
that each Hospital collected their own
data and so it was the value you got
reached hospital was the median
aggregated value for the hospital so you
can have hospital one and you know you
can have hospital one in New York and it
would have probably a hundred patients
but you'd only get the value of that
median of those hundred patients for the
hospital
thank you
[Applause]